[Music]
hello everybody hope you're happy in
here children it's nice yeah as you
mentioned I'm a CPA and fatty aromatic
calcite like a lot of top here so
hopefully we'll go through it quick and
that's it's something that I love it
let's start by talking a good slides
talking about a tiara then I'll talk a
little bit about Romeo I'm having these
there are a few things that we can use
some examples and notebooks and how to
access different types data I'm going to
go into some of the second we do it
which we call retouches which is form
caching and how that could include good
things and show you some examples of
what that impeccable looks like so sort
of at the top so why why I started a
company and what we were thinking about
was this is like getting a data rate for
analysis to heart this is true whether
you're an analyst or a scientist or a
product manager who just needs to find
the data to solve question hard to find
the data many of the data systems that
are very great for developers and have
massive scale are not necessarily built
for analysis purposes a necessary part
of into the data base
so the standard ones that we all love
this is never a single system anymore so
I think this is so beautiful like the 15
years ago that did lakes for assault
Walberg get a distribution probably
drinking with me on Monday too late but
the reality is is that I've never
happened this happens very very rarely
and so usually you have to be able to do
this many many different systems so
those systems can be very sort of
old-school like filers with csps as I
was just mentioning to make and then
there's new stuff where it's like hey
what's that it was no sequel database
that might be out there data access is
frequently slow specifically optimized
for OTP purposes not for analytical
purposes and time to get challenged as
well and so what happens is that we see
a lot is people have to open tables to
be before more technical to access to do
it and they would like because
overactive central IT and I have to open
up a ticket I did this is how I'm going
to get to this data and there's also
this issue where when I asked for the
data I don't know exactly what the right
answer is so they don't get some data
and then I'll realize if there's
problems with that they don't need to go
back and central IT and ask for more
questions and so really what we said is
hey if it means to be we need to improve
this process right there's going to be
need for every part you did if I - risk
invasive identify IT need in an
engineering certain data cleansing at
different levels all that something's
who exists is nervous so a simplified
way to do this way that's more
self-service and so what we say this we
started out with sort of a variant based
problem which is when we're thinking
about data so if you think about data
infrastructure today it's kind of what I
would call a loosely coupled ecosystem
there are lots of different tools that
are good for service or use cases and
you really want to approach data with
the best of rate approach and the
problem is is that moving data between
different systems can be very very
expensive and so before we even built up
a product it drove me over
started up a project called Apache arrow
many of you probably heard of Apache
arrow its goal is pretty simple which is
that we want to have a canonical
representation of data in memory so that
we can speed both inner interchange
between different systems and processing
of data in general and so the human of
opportunity is there so there was a
colander in the reformat focused on not
only simple data but all sorts of
complicated patterns that we see in
real-world data and it's a matching
foundation project which means that is
consensus driven we have thirteen or
fourteen different open contributors
from thirteen or fourteen different open
source projects at least is more now
that are contributing to Apache arrow so
it's something that's not alone by
anyone have even designed to be a
collaborative approach to how to solve
this problem and really this is kind of
a chicken and an egg thing going on over
there
so we will looking at the world and
we're saying hey how do we make it so
they're loosely coupled ecosystem we
don't spend all our time of these heroes
nation so there's lots of analysis out
that that's been done so that the arrow
stuff eventually people done it to where
you can actually look at the end of
pipelines if you start to move between
different systems you might spend
somewhere between 80 and 90 percent of
your resources against the inci relation
and easy relation of moving between
those systems and there's kind of two
reasons to that what is is that each
system has its own internal
representation of data and so when we
want to move from one system to another
you have to take the internal
representation exposed that is some kind
of API and then the other side of the
system of the other systems in the
interactivity yeah turn it into its
internal representation and there's two
problems there are what is this that all
this conversions the other is that Jim
must begin the inner lake the interface
between the two is an API and that means
immutably you're going to sell myself
access that that data move it from one
format to the other format so that's
just a lot of processing overhead as
well and so era said hey how do we solve
this well we solved this by trying to
get so that more people use the same
representation of data with the
processing it you know convincing
someone to change the internal
representation inside of the system is
very difficult right so that's how long
it's gonna be a long process to get
people to sort of stopped it but one of
the things that we saw is key to that is
is that the representation needs to be
highly efficient for processing the
reason you have a different internal
representation versus an external
representation is because you need an
intern representation that's fast for
processing if a common format that you
can pass between different systems is
very efficient passing between systems
but isn't fast for processing well then
each systems would come up with their
own internal representation and there's
spent a lot of time losing between those
two and so we actually looked at it and
solved first for the processing use case
and said how do you represent data
efficient manner so that you can process
it well with longer CPUs and that
basically led us to the reputation can
where we line things up in a common
format we have a bunch of different
things that we do around that to make it
have an efficient and you have sort of
patterns of how we use shredded
representations for omelettes dated a
bunch of other things and so that so
which one's the chicken the egg I don't
know but basically solve for processing
performance and people will start to
adopt it for processing performances and
they can also adopt it for interchange
because now the seminar system to
communication and so that's really what
the arrows about there's three main
components to arrow and just to keep in
mind arrow is a fairly low level
technology it's designed to be used by
people who are building tools so that
people who are using tools can have much
better performance so the three
components I type so as I think about it
our core set of libraries so what I call
building blocks and then some in example
integrations there so for libraries
basically we're adding lay which is on
our time so that you can interact there
or no matter what language you're in
right and so one of the most common
patterns that people are starting to aro
product for our movement between JDM
base stuff and non-gm base stuff so I've
got a Python or C++ application and
unfortunately a bunch of my stuff is
inside of some 15 technology returned to
the gym yeah the JVM is not very good at
playing with others and so you can use
arrow to represent that data inside of
the JVM and then you can simply connect
that memory down to the other
application without any external RAM
so that's the core set of libraries as
sort of top of the list here so the more
mature ones down at the bottom
javascript rust those are things that
are kind of have any more recently but I
think we're already using them in a lot
of products and production on top of
that I basically talked about some sort
of building blocks that we're building
inside of the arrow community so two
examples are plasma feather so plasma is
a shared memory cache
originally created inside the great
project and then you also have feather
which is a fast ephemeral form data
format for running data quickly that's
in the narrow representation so it might
be knit like I don't I hide you know
moving doing two processes I don't know
how I ever solved yes your remember
meeting mr. processes what I can do is I
can find find the pedophile quickly the
disk at the other process open up the
pedophile pull it back in the memory and
it's very very efficient to additional
projects that we're working on one is
called Arab RBC which is a standard way
for different systems to communicate
with each other using arrows or a
presentation and this isn't to be
involved a single and a parallel stream
interface so one of the things that
happens is that you may have what is a
narrative data set and you want to pass
that to another system very efficiently
but those are both distributed systems
so that error the our RPC will also
support a parallel read interface the
last piece that we're working on is
something called the error of kernels
and this is really sort of driving
another way for people to understand and
start to take advantage of error and so
imagine you have a situation today where
you're trying to figure out how to come
up quickly to come up with a dictionary
efficiently as possible using on their
CDs are you trying to sort of get it
very very quickly and so whatever
kernels are are they small processing
library that's processing tasks that you
can apply to an error representation as
quickly as possible turn it into the
numeric error facilitation and so here's
trying to solve for a system that has
one of these needs you can pick up one
of these kernels and if you get the data
into error representation opposite
Indians operations very very quickly and
so for some of you that listen to the
well talk right one of the things that
we
look at is combining heavy well consumed
with reduce arrow so that it has an
another way of sort of because that is
an advanced internal I'm running out to
outside the arrow project that's kind of
whatever most other little things in the
process certain things so that you can
start to take advantage of the air
representation as quickly as possible
and then lastly arrow integration so
there were several days two of the big
ones is Candace's using it as a primary
insurer representation for many things
now and spark has adopted that as a way
to move back and forth between Python
and spark representation and so there's
two there Parque and arrow are very sort
of closely related started by some of
the same people and so part case and I
think it was the canonical on disk
representation of data they I was trying
to become the company memory
representation of data so we have a
bunch of integrations to make it very
fast in between one at the other the GPU
open analytics initiative is driving the
gene data frame the JTF and using an
arrow is the representation to do that
and then lastly the thing I'm going to
talk about today
Dromio is an open source project patchy
license that also uses your arrow as
their entire representation for digna
throughout our processing power so arrow
arrow started less than two years ago
I think something like that huge amount
of adoption aren't happy with the
progress on it still a long ways to go
to make it actually be in every single
tool that you're using today but I think
we did at the end this is a partial
chart here but I think at the end of
last year we did one hundred thousand
dollars a month for arrow so arrow is
the base how would we start to deal with
data in sort of a more common way and
then on top of that we said hey how do
we make it so that it's more easy to get
access to data and that's what the red
videos about so as I mentioned driven
taxi license project it's built on top
of that we're talking about the right
hand side here first I guess build a
type of Apache arrow actually calcite
Apache
okay it's really designed to make it
easier to access your data
it's tended by the company that I worked
at we launched the product last July so
it's a fairly new products but have
that's new year and really far the
self-service data access platform
available and then lastly there's
question the narwhal who is our logo is
an army which is one of those situations
where someone suggested it as a jest and
then it's not so what do you what is it
running out specifically he said I'll
get the demo in just a second so a
couple slides here but Jeremy I would
think of it as Google Docs for your data
as a way to collaborate around data
access and data endpoints data assets
where people are less focused on the
mechanical side of data so the goal is
is that you really separate on the
concept that logical data versus didn't
look so physical data should be dealt
with because of like choices around
performance or security and those kinds
of things logical data should be the
thing that most users interact with and
you should be able to separate those two
things out that's Jeremy what trivia is
really about and so poor that is a UI
taxes that her dead as well as data
curation so being able to manipulate
data without having to always open up
tickets and get other people that
support you love that we actually break
the sort of pieces of what we're trying
to provide here into four main
components right hand side data catalog
and in a curation so I got a fine ass at
my gate assets wherever they are and I
need
relate that I have an open tickets all
the time but also on top of that is data
caching so if lots of people are
accessing the same data regularly well
then there's a benefit to maybe
maintaining alternative physical
representations of that data you make an
access faster independent of the
specific logical way that people are
looking at it and then lastly well I'm
going to actually access the data itself
so I've got to talk to different systems
and some time you know has a bunch of
different sources that it can interact
with owners of the systems so one of the
things that we think about is is that
this self-service data access layer is
about providing sort of a common
interface for data but not moving here
so we don't argue the trivial drive is
not a system of record singing use your
existing systems of records which are
probably many that simply use gêmeos an
easier way to get sort of common
interfacing with this so without further
ado I will switch over and hopefully
show you a little demo here
so the demo gods are kind of course so
quickly here this is the drum you know
homepage I'm logged in as myself here
and you start out in your your home
space where you can have sort of
different projects that you're working
on so you can so any dream you know the
objects that we deal with are basically
always data sets their data that you're
interact with for one purpose or another
and then you have echo sources so as I
mentioned in Joanna has a bunch of
different sources did you access here
some of them here basically think about
sort of relational mix with a bunch of a
sort of more most common sort of know
sinkholes
it makes that kind of thing and so for
each of these things we want to make
those as look as similar as possible and
so for example here I've actually got
cysts or so so she is connected to
trimming off this moment we've actually
made these for demo purposes based on
what the systems are but the reality is
is that they actually could be named in
a misleading way it wouldn't matter and
realistically the most
our customers use it they actually need
them based on business concept so maybe
it's the marketing database and the
customer retention database and
something else care right the individual
systems really no distracted away and so
for example you actually have the same
gated [ __ ] elasticsearch here so we've
got some this Yelp a descendant people
like music demo ESS so I've got another
here at ma girl and so we map along with
databases tuned Romeo holders we map
among the collections to in Germany no
tables or data sets in elasticsearch we
actually have indexes here aliases and
those given than the individual types
inside of those things get mapped to
data sets so we try to abstract this
away and so if you're looking at
something like a new cluster
we're so kind of on a dinner leg then
what happen is is that we have folders
here which is just me traversing it data
set actually remove the format here so
what happens is when you first come into
this stuff you actually see you actually
a steam a little folders like this so
this is just more folders in here
okay there we go yeah so this is just a
folder with a bunch of text files
this one over here another folder with a
bunch of text policy and so what drove
me allows you to do is say okay well I
want to convert this text files it's
gonna drive us gonna do this best I
presume didn't go to much it looks like
we're using the wrong field the limiter
so I'm gonna it's the field love it
right here okay that looks good that's
now a data set inside of tremana so the
idea is is that whatever data that
you're looking at you always have a
basic standard canonical names sort of
path that is a this is data set called
HDFS updated lone stock position and so
that can be used in any kind of context
inside of mu as a dataset and the user
doesn't have to know whether or not
there's a representation of the data set
for logical representation of the SS
they can just sort of interact with it
as an endpoint and they may only have
access to some portions of those things
right and so let's go back here so
that's that's kind of very quickly how
that Romeo works so thinking about it
from a notebook perspective this is just
sort of go through here I have a little
notebook here with some access hopefully
that's big enough for people seen back
there I've got a little set up at the
moment we're connecting to the dromio
using odbc what we're working on as I
mentioned in arrow RBC and that would be
the primary interface that we use moving
forward but that's not complete yet and
so that's why reasoning to see is so the
more standard thing use restaurant in DC
or whatever your different kinds of
situations anyway so so I'm going to
said defines accessibility of your
building methods here and then basically
Indra Mia everything is a schema and so
let me be seen happens to expose things
as two levels but we as I showed you
with I'm happy for and have an arbitrary
number of levels and so I'll plot those
out into schema name as basically all
the things that's the legal thing and
then we can go into one of those things
so this example I'm gonna go I think
used along with data set among gonna
Yelp did is have to move in there and
then you can see in all the tables that
are available inside the system and so
let's start interaction with the data so
what I'll do is I'm actually going to
run a query here against this to get
some data so one of the first things
that derivative does is that during a
C's complex data so if you looking at
MongoDB for example today it can be
complex and can also be arbitrarily
scheming right and so what Jeremy will
do is it'll sample the schema expose
that to the user and then it has to be
read more and more data from the system
you will actually identify these schemas
and so for example the first record
inside of a mullah table could be when
the columns could be an integer in the
second record that same column could be
a struct with some listeners out of it
right there's an artist there's no rules
around this
who supports that exposes tools for you
to sort of deal with those energy types
and also constantly samples and learns
from those samples so that the user can
interact with the stuff even if this
stuff is kind of a mess okay so if you
go back to how you expose this stuff to
other tools well what we do is that
because OBC doesn't have a great
interface for complex data what we do is
something very simple isn't anything
that's complex or doesn't fit into sort
of standard traditional relational
schema stuff we actually member it
always to JSON even if the end of line
representation it happens to be
something completely different the data
going back we'll always be JSON when
it's a complex type and so what I can do
inside that I thought has a cognition
use in a patentable so here for example
resume didn't much here but there's an
hour's column so the categories
composition array and then there's an
hour's call which is as a map and the
map has some different powers of side of
it and so what we can do is is that a
little too big here just see okay but
basically we're going to look at one of
these things and grab the hours field
okay now let's come back as a JSON
representation which I've parsed using
Python tools and I can grab either that
the certain value for what time the
restaurant was a surprise so that's
that's what you can do so if you use the
tools that you already have you to say
hey let me get some records back and
start playing with them you can also use
gem you know if you want to expose this
stuff we're commonly I want to build a
around it and so here I'm actually asked
for the exact same value which is our
stuff Friday got close and though the
next Romeo to get that for me and then
return it for me and so what this allows
you to do is it allows you to define you
data and points inside the dream you
know that expose certain fields and so a
user may not not all users may
understand complex data types but you
want to expose it to another user you
can create did it in the point which
exposes if it is by the way inside of
dream you know as a virtual data set
then they can do that so just to give
you a better example sort of curated I'm
going to here look at the model go go
look at the businesses inside of one we
go this is the data we were just looking
at before as I mentioned there's a
categories column here which is an array
of things and so if I'm a user trying to
analyze this stuff maybe one of the
first things I want to do is I want to
clean it up they don't want to do two
things with it so whatever the is I just
clicked in here I mean business monthly
up so right now it's purple which it was
physical data set but I actually want to
save it as a virtual data set inside of
my access space my business okay so now
all of a sudden now this is an endpoint
that I can share with other people and I
can choose to change the dish that in
many ways based on whatever I think
support and so for example maybe I want
to collapse these things out of a race
because I know that user interactive
it's not gonna be able to deal with
great so that i put in this damn it
tonight and then over here I'm gonna go
okay I think that I actually won't
extract the zip code because there's no
field for zip code so it's going to
suggest some different things I'm gonna
say that this was good
try to basically look at different
patterns and see which one works the
best and then propose that pattern so
here I've got a zip code column and now
say that this is now in point that I can
use so I could go back over here and put
that in here something I just did and
now as a user I can start interacting
with access my business and expose that
to other users and they have no idea
like we've already forgotten that I
remember dad says mom goes up on the
table but the user doesn't have to know
about that
we've manipulated it and edit virtually
so there's no need for us to make a copy
of the data and start passing that
around and if you want to you can go
into the product and understand where
something comes from so this example
actually see this with my business
perfect it's gonna find your the
physical representation of that which
happens to be coming from a mobile
database so you can go and then look at
these different virtual visits build
them on top of each other and share
those with different people and so
different levels of technical expertise
can be lift with different levels of
data lifting right so someone just
doesn't have such sophistication might
work with things that are curated but
someone who's more of a power user might
be able to go to more to raw sources and
interact that data directly I know where
it's problem so anyway so that's there
and at the same time what we constantly
see with users this is something we
actually didn't originally plan but they
only saw a bunch of users were actually
having this pattern which is is that
frequently you've got a bunch of big
data system stuff but then you've also
got some stuff that's sort of personal
to you and so for example you might be
trying to understand what's going on
with a certain set of customers and so
you've got a customer listing Excel is
the 45
actually and you combine that with the
other data to try to figure out the set
of information that you're looking at
and so let me also allow you to actually
upload it and import that and then
expose that as additional data in points
this cool part here so I say that and so
now this is available as an endpoint
just like anything else and so yeah that
is not currently available to anybody
else because it's in my space so home
spaces are private but if I want to say
that as a virtual data set in a public
space did not give me a kind of data
available out of people so it's
something that's something and there's
my Excel spreadsheet for analysis so
that's about just basic access now
thinking about access that's great that
I can expose to different systems but
won't experience this is that you want
to leverage the underlying systems as
much as possible because the trivial
amounts of it it's fine for you so you
pull the data back into Dromio driven
stuff to the processing but we were
talking about big data systems it's very
frequently the case that you want to
actually do as much work in the
underlying system as possible an
examples elastic search right elastic
search is great at using as index to get
to do it very quickly filtering down
into certain sense of records if you
actually ask elastic search to return a
large amounts of records to you it's row
speed is extremely slow it can turn
something like 50 or had a dozen records
per second per thread or something like
that something very small comparison the
other representations seeing 111 see
systems as much as possible and so
here's an example of where we're going
to actually so what we did instead of
driving as we're trying to expose these
systems as much as possible and so in
some cases their systems that have
specialized capabilities in example that
is elastic search where we said hey
elastic search have is the ability to do
all sorts of arbitrary unstructured
searches and so how do we expose that in
trim you know we said well we're trying
to model is around the sequel so let's
expose it as a contains pot so you
my sequel Oracle all these different
systems they have something called
contains which is a way of using the
default in full-text indexing to find
things and so we actually expose that
inside it from you we expose it using
these things that the scenes in tax and
so in this example I'm gonna go and go
and look at the reviews and what I'm
going to be looking for are things where
we see awkward in date and this is where
you would need to know who scene syntax
to expose this we try to expose this
power in this example were actually been
a proximity search we're saying we want
awkward and date to be within two words
of each other right and so if you wanted
to do this without something like this
tool it would take you quite a bit of
time and but it's something that
elasticsearch was very good at and so I
could get that pull this back actually
pull off the cell which is the text in
it and there I can see a here's the
first example of an awkward date I got
when I searched from drum you know into
elasticsearch right so that just so you
know everything that I've done up until
now has been entirely based on what we
call in situate limits which is
interacting with the underlying source
driven doesn't hold any of the data
simply passed through a mechanism to get
the data it back to you you use a common
interface and then we try to figure out
the right way to interact into our
system so in this case this operation I
think I actually don't have this one
operation I would know it so well that's
also good in aggregations and so here I
have something where I might want to be
saying hey let me roll up how many
reviews there were organized by stars
looking at that might here right and so
this happens to be something that
elastic search is very good at just pop
it right here and so I just ran that
query that's aquariums get turned into
elastic searches internal representation
of how this specify queries in parallel
drove interacted with so multiple
mathematics or charts got the dancer
turned it back into
that is okay so that's the result that
we got there and this is actually
anything query that we generated and
send in parallel fuel elasticsearch if
you're interested and so this is
basically the way that you talk to
elastic search he was applying here
we're finding a date range with a
certain elastic search time across the
time stamp format we're saying whether
or not good the lower upper bounds and
then we do several layers aggregations
around the Stars and month and they
actually in this case push down the
groovy script to do some kind of
operation around getting a year and so
what we're trying to do is basically
distract us all the stuff away it's not
that you can put in write this script to
do it but really we think you should be
can get out more about analyzing data
and if you want to do the data and
trying to figure out how we do the
system suppose this data so the same is
true for the other system true for the
other systems there we interact with and
so it gives an example of long ago push
down so here we're going to do another
education which is account at the stars
are review and we're applying that to
amazing I think this one takes a little
bit longer there's a bit slow here let's
see if we wait and see if they know
about dependent of us resolve your name
yeah
so there's identity answer so anyway we
push down stuff again in this example
I'm actually going to search for giving
you these stars or things that have the
word amazing in them and so this is
actually pushing an array of expression
into [ __ ] to figure out this filter and
then doing the aggregation of [ __ ] as
well so all that time actually is in
[ __ ] it's doing this kind of just
passable through the space and as we
might expect people who say amazing
Germany rate that review is very very
high right there are a lot of one-star
reviews say amazing
it's not something that's using the
overview and so example just as before
we come up with what's the right syntax
that this happens to be the syntax that
we use to run this operation because we
need to use the aggregation pipeline to
do this but again try to distract the
ways to users
active now we also interact with
relational databases and as much as
you'd like to think the relational
differences are all the same they're not
and so again we try to abstract that
away so the user doesn't have to be
thinking about which relational database
I'm using and how can I write the
question correctly and so for example
here we're running a query against a
little bit one against Oracle table and
if you might remember Oracle doesn't do
limit why the fact that you have two
doesn't support limit you have to use
Rotom and so we need or smart enough to
figure that out here's an example where
we get something a single server in this
case we're going to extract of the year
which is a standard single contact
concept the sequel server doesn't
support it and actually single serve it
also doesn't use the same putting so off
suddenly Benes brackets and we've got to
use your function as opposed to distract
syntax before so the goal being that no
matter what the system is is as the
German abstract that away so you're
distracting and wedding with
complexities at the underlying system
are you're also extracting away whatever
those with durations you want to do
before the user start interacting with
things and then users themselves can
manipulate and change these things in
that you
each other they realize it's a weakness
to the other point is the asset that's a
sort of a lower level organizational
person has provided so that's about
access okay so go into the second part
which is about caching right and so what
we've seen is is that people often
interact with the same data in the same
way okay and what happens is that you
build these giant clusters of systems to
try to process and deal with data the
same way multiple times because there
isn't a great way for people to
collaborate around in concepts and so if
you think about it like accessing data
it's good right but what we see is is
that it's often too slow and that's
actually one of the biggest sort of
blockers to analysis is that you're
constantly waiting for results to come
back to you or constantly waiting for
Tanager constant waiting for something
rather than just thinking that things
are being the flow and so one of the
things we say is is that we want to
figure out ways to decrease the distance
the data so the first is an access but
then it's like how much work needs to be
done to actually get my answers right so
you can think about that in many ways
it's like how much how much data
manipulation happens needs to happen how
much movement it did to assistance needs
that happen how long does that thing
take to complete and so Jeremy
introduced this concept of reflections
and the reflection is an alternative
version of the data that is closer to
what you want okay and it could be
closer because it's on a system that's
closer if you like it can be physically
closer it could be closer because it's a
representation that is faster in a
process so if the row speed of
elasticsearch is slow and you know
you're already always interacting
last 30 days with additional asset
search making pathetic representation
that's much more efficient it could be a
representation of data that is closer to
the question you are asking
so I've got a very large table and will
constantly ask it a question around you
know something where I'm doing some
level of summarization or aggregation
then possibly we could have a person did
it somewhat partially summarize that you
closer to your relative and so that
relationship can be fairly complicated
in that the data you might need to
answer a question to be possibly
comfortable in places maybe
summarization answers part of your
question and so it gives you a pre
summarized version of data some of it
but then you may also want to use the
raw data for some other part of your
question and so you want to be able to
balance these things and this is
something that everybody does already
which is this then if you know you have
a use case which you benefit from having
the alternative representation of data
people creating alternate
representations of data all the time
what happens is is that you didn't
create lots of these representations and
you have to rely on the users to figure
out what the right representation used
to get the optimal experience okay and
this is where it starts to break down as
your mission gets larger you have larger
a large number of these data sets of
people to interact with you also have a
problem to change control where these
dates that's kind of promised this
really the data set that I wanted to
look at and so trivial basically trying
to solve that part of the problem too
and so I said everything is separated
out with a logical or physical and so
when we're talking about reflection in
the cache that's all physical right so
you interact with this data endpoints
you do whatever you want but what we
want to be able to do is allow users to
also people who serve and there's
systems more allow them to sort of set
different distance around what can be
cached whether the colonist around yeah
that might be allowed to be a little bit
stale and day-old or an hour old
and make alternative representations and
so what happens is is that so how you do
it today is on the left hand side here
which is as they use a copy of
expression you create different copies
of data for different versions different
use cases and then you ask the analyst
or data scientists to pick the right
representation for their purposes but
Romeo tries to do is say hey we may want
to create alternative representations
what we call reflections for different
purposes from a physical standpoint but
the user should not have to interact
with those or ask for the particular
thing that's best for them
ramune can actually make that decision
for you so as you're going through an
analysis it may mean that you start with
one you may start with a picture of
logical endpoint and then we recognize
that based on the way that you're
interacting with that end point where
that physical data said we actually
realized that an alternative version of
that didn't mean faster and we swap it
in and so we're constantly in every
operation comes they look at all the
different versions of data that we have
trying to figure out what's the best one
to swap it and so here's a couple of
examples of how this works there's a lot
of different ways that this works but
the model is basically the same which is
that if you imagine the left-hand side
here this might give an operation that
you're trying to do your data on the
middle here are different reflections or
materializations that we have that we're
using to try to see whether or not we
can make things go faster and so in this
first example we have something which is
an aggregation so I'm doing I'm scanning
taking one I'm doing a rejection of a
and C I am then doing the entire game of
a sum you see a scene crime and then I'm
going to filter on see crime right so
this might be interacting with broad day
that might be billions of records but
some of may have actually printed a
reflection are one that are one
reflection is actually defined as an
aggregation of a and
celibacy okay it's a trivia we'll look
at second one I have this reference
function which matches part of what you
want it's not exactly what you want but
it's part of it and so I'm actually
going to rewrite your query so that it
takes the management center line
reflection and then all the sudden that
query is actually a is an operation on
top of reflection one whether an
additional roll-ups trying to get to the
subset of data that you're interested in
and then applies the filter anyone and
so driven is constantly trying to look
at these opportunities to try and make
it so that when you do things it's going
to go faster but the user didn't realize
it you know doesn't have to worry about
and so that means that as you can see in
different use cases where you need
things to go faster you can create your
reflections and without changing any of
the consumption of those data sets the
operation is compassion so here's a
couple other examples as well if you
have a join with some aggregations we
can actually appear at different ways to
map these things together and then also
it may be that you're interacting with
raw data maybe you have a use case where
you're trying to do a lot of
needle-in-a-haystack gnostics right it's
a different partitioning or sorting
strategy of the raw data maybe with only
a subset of columns by being better to
make your make your operations go faster
and so Jeremy I can also have that so
you can have different reflections of
the underlying data partitioning some
advice by one field and partition sort
by another and the drug will do constant
at each of those always looking to see
what's the fastest path to enhancer so
no matter what happen is you basically
have the user interact with those logic
plan points and then drug you tries to
figure out the right example and so
quickly go over here so here's a quick
example of this I have another set up
here so here's a we have this is a
little this little three cluster notice
how to do what compute and we're going
to count on New York taxi so this is the
taxi trips for like five years with the
data I think there's a billion records
okay so that operation I just ran was
was interacting with Jerome you know I
have no idea whether or not there
against New York taxi enough trips I'm
just interacting with that if the data
set so let's look at actually what's
wrong yet I said it is I can see here
okay here's a couple of rows from the
taxi trips data okay it's that pickup
drop-off times passenger count stays
like that okay so the user feels like
they're interacting with the raw data
right but let's say that they're
fascinating question which we've got a
partial summarization for and so in this
example I'm going to look at the number
of trips screeching okay it's a very
simple example but that's this big more
so so I'm gonna run this and drive isn't
going to get it out now I just read a
query so it's just sort of to rehab here
I just ran an aggregation on a billion
records on a three node cluster and less
than the same the user has no idea the
dromio has a reflection which makes this
go faster and they don't need to know
right they interacted with the raw data
they can interact with the raw data and
they can take advantage of these things
and so Jeremy I'll just said he you know
what happened to the version of that
recommendation of data its way closer to
your answer we're not dealing with
billion records right now we can't be
doing the video records right now so you
can think of reflections kind of like
the dances right so when you go and
search Google right you maybe turn it
may search you know whatever the
training documents that it hasn't
sitting exciting with the number but it
doesn't mean just search all those
rights got representations of data that
are closer to what your question is so
they can come back in sub second time
it's the same with let's say hey let's
have them to purpose of patients and as
users ask questions we can clear up what
the best representation has to this
question as quickly as possible
and so as I mentioned that may also be
working with
subsets of data so this example here I
wanted to interact with something that
actually
Roger right so if I'm going to do a
build a machine learning model I might
want to say hey I would look at all the
trips that happen on the fourth of July
I want to see what the patterns are in
New York on the fourth of July and so
here's an example of doing that and so
this is using different kind of
reflection which allows us to go back at
the appointment varies against the data
as quickly as possible and so I wrap up
realistic problems and so again come
back very very quickly and if I wanted
then load that into a data frame easy to
avoid initial analysis only point a
hundred thousand back here but here I
can pull back you pull well back all
that raw data and still think you've
answered your question so the users
moving back and forth between
interacting with the raw data
interacting with different reflections
of the data but they have no idea and
that's that's the goal right is that
they don't need to have an idea they can
simply take advantage of how fast things
are and how things look all the same so
[Music]
so I'll send out the slides there's a
whites here if you want to ask questions
feel free come to me I'm going on for
hours directly after this go down with
the product about you yeah yeah listen
it's a great question I think that the
short answer today is is that we don't
believe that the salts ever did
engineering problem we're not even close
to that our goal is to solve some of the
small unfortunately to get engineering
problems that are closer to consumers
but we believe that it's within like a
range of tools that are beyond this and
so we actually have a number of concepts
that we were actually exactly just
concept of extra reflections where you
can use any engineering tooling want to
produce alternative representations it's
just a inform dreaming of what they are
and still expose that logical view so
we're trying to figure out ways that you
can use whatever tool you want so if you
want to bust out of the the abstraction
because you wanna do something super
fancy you can be cached what if I yeah
so so in terms of controls you actually
control around the datasets so every day
is that has policies around how it can
be updated and how scaled it is allowed
to be before we actually refresh things
so dromio guarantees that you always
maintain the SLA that is remote that is
sent for each data center interact you
can set some SLA is to say I won't do
any reflections here instead other just
aminute is that this is not changing
very much you said that in a day and
then maybe gets into the changing
frequently my sense of five minutes
being in control the escalate or data
set level can also control how we give
updates to a new partially updates with
old updates and services
you